une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nous inviter dates ci dessus ph
canton avec moi cette semaine d'une
plante le podcast cette semaine et
présenté par planethoster planethoster
c'est une société d'hébergement web pour
la collecte de cette semaine on a fait
affaire avec eux en fait pour nous me
grey notre site web va planethoster
c'est toi qui s'en est chargé puis
c'était vraiment un service à la
clientèle de bombes
moi je voyais des emails qui arrivait à
toute heure de la nuit pkp quitter dès à
chaque étape de la transition en fait
puis planethoster of la balance de votre
compte gratuitement donc vous donner un
exemple si vous aviez 12 mois avec le
fournisseur que vous aviez vous avez
jusqu'à - vous voulez transférer vers
planethoster mais plein auster vous
offre huit mois gratuitement
c'est autant bardon autant pour des
particuliers qui veulent un petit blog
d'un musique pour des grandes
entreprises avec des sites web très
complexe en passant par des pme comme
studio sf qui ont besoin d'un site web
bernard ridge dans le fond si vous êtes
une obnl organisme à but non lucratif
plaintes reçues vous donne 25 % de
rabais pour vous donner un coup de main
et si vous voulez 1 25% label je
m'adresse à tout le monde on a un code
pour moi pour vous autres c'est le ph a
trait d'union sans trait d'union filtres
comme le nom du podcast pour 25 % de
rabais sur n'importe quoi que vous allez
vous procurer sur planethoster sinon
c'est cette semaine on a reçu un
humoriste que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle creech en fait que j'ai connu
surtout avec en fait quitté maurice mais
aussi youtube a dans le fond parce que
y'a une chaîne youtube avec son ami abah
abah et rich qui font des vidéos
bilingue mais surtout en anglais où ils
vont parler de soi de sujets mais
souvent des lipides actualité ou des
polémiques les quelque chose qui se
passe puis ils vont rentrer était ce
sujet le puits moi j'ai vraiment
accrochés sur leur chaîne je trouve que
leur opinion est fondée à nuancer c'est
pas idéologique laissé poste à gauche
qu'à droite c'est juste du gros bon sens
sont drôles sont excellents alors avec
plus on a passé aussi je demande le
courage que ça prend de s'attaquer ou
d'être traités de toutes ces sujets
délicats et cholet qui ne racontaient
que ça y est pas toujours valu à fait
perdu des amis carrément en étant en
s'attaquant ces sujets le mec il pense
que c'est nécessaire je demande qu'on en
parle parce qu'il ya trop de choses dont
on a peur de parler dans notre société
et lui il n'y a pas pas alors c'est
super le fun belle rencontre des
conversations ouais puis vous n'écoutez
présentement peu importe la plateforme
participé à condensation les cellules
des commentaires que ce soit sur audio
seulement sur youtube les sinon un petit
like abonnés voir nos chaînes partout et
sinon wait and see vous n'écoutez sur
balles à dos tout ça ça fait son bout de
chemin
on commence à cumuler une grande base
doute store puis on aime ce donc plus de
gens parlez-en à vos proches en fonte et
rien de mieux que le bon vieux bouche à
oreille donc sur ce bon pas de castres y
est
[Musique]
yes et commencer les tomates en eau
martin manille il disait je me lève des
fois je me lève le matin puis séchés
bout portant mais jo sans enfant de la
france c'est mon laptop ou un bon
téléphone s'est fissuré métriques
réactif fois j'active exactement positif
la matin pour écrire le dga et pis un
sponsor pour écrire et gaillac et pour
mouvement pour écrire et gagne pour
toucher j'ai à faire défaut c'est juste
la paperasse défaut c'est juste penser à
faire la recherche veut pas pour le
projet qu'on fabrique faut qu'on fasse
la référence paraît qu'il y en a là
c'est le fun est drôle sauf que on veut
pas dire de la marne non plus qu'on voit
pas est ce qu'on dit sur des faits
affection que oui c'est enrobé sans
rabais dans le secret joyeux poésie kobe
quelque chose qui aide à avaler la
pilule mais essentiellement des digues
et des faits avant l'heure de ce mois
c'est ce qu'elle fait c'est ce qui est
le plus impressionnant dans votre
chambre qui le plus intéressant de mon
point de vue c'est pas je sais oui c'est
le fun que ce soit drôle mais crise il
ya quand même du travail derrière ce
ouais bah sa part de comment moi
j'apprends à comprendre les choses si
j'apprends avec des exemples
mon imac au kg à l'école c'était cela le
prof qui étaient abandonnées dit des
trucs même aux techniques techniques ou
des affaires que des trucs ou de deux
tonnes de montrer genre parallèle avec
qui occupent d'accord c'est le rappelle
pourquoi pas d'autres parce que j'ai un
exemple quelconque effet que j'étais
capable d'absorber l'information comme
astral hausse que de quelques jeunes
inventeurs que je parie sur le même
institut des châteaux couteau toute
l'épreuve de philosophie au cégep et je
tenterai pas si c'était juste monotone
fait qu avec de l'humour avec the sarah
entrées pour aucune raison que ce c'est
bon ben moi ça fait longtemps que j'ai
longtemps ça fait un bon moment qui vous
suit il avait depuis lé début de
podcasts j'en parle à péage cbt ou à
bonn puis faut les invités sont vraiment
bons puis je trouve en plus que si on a
parlé je savais que t'arrive t ous êtes
quand même courage de vous frotter à
certains sujets courageux du web
il n'avait pas par mendy ce chapeau vrai
parce qu'il tire justement quelqu'un
d'une controverse plonger dedans fait
traiter de tous les noms
bah ouais mais c'est ça parce que
parlant de ces sujets là comme je
regardais et je me rappelle plus je
crois que c'était tombé en amour avec
une personne france ouais c'est votre
vidéo je pense qu'ils avaient été le
plus vu ou alors les vidéos qui me
donnait comme ici on commentait sur le
web ouais on commenté justement ce jeu
ça commence juste pourriez-vous tombé en
amour avec quatre ans mercy est ce que
tu es super trophée pourrait sinon est
ce que tu peux dire que ça fait avec
elles n'ont pas ou transforme non puis
juste voit sur cette vidéo le son en
avait 12 ans paul avait du vent on ne
m'aime pas je souffre douleur mais c'est
surtout la partie gpu dégâts causés
ouais parce que je dispose est
responsable mais de quoi pour la fierté
a guidé correcte des signes et peut-être
justement un groupe de personnes trans
qui vont qui sont voilà quand c'est à
cause de douleurs ou d'autres virus ne
souhaite traiter de damas fois
d'homophobe trafford mu et gêne puis ça
qu'est ce qui te laisse là dedans c'est
que ces gens le dans la culture de la
consolation tant qu'ils veulent de
conseillers pour un truc comme ça ils
pensent qu'ils font mal il faut le
transformer en un mois ou qui étaient ça
ça va être un nom ne sera pas d'argent
puisque ce blabla mais c'est pas la
réalité car concédée contre avec des
compagnies comme ça on s'aimait contre
d'annulation comme quoi ceux ci aux
autres manuels ou cancel dans une
certaine période de temps fram qui me
paye un certain montant d'argent fait
six mois qu'il forma si l'organisme
pendant tellement j'ai pas performé de
ce pays trompant fixé comme c'est dit et
comme un quelqu'un qui est qui qui qui
dépensent de l'argent pourquoi j'espère
sincèrement je veux arrêter quelqu'un
doit évidemment faux seins de damart là
pour ça parce que moi j'ai bouclé cette
journée le refuser d'autres charges pour
refuser d'autres choses pour des glands
où il faut courir de la marge dans la
passe mais ça on vient au sujet
ça tombe pas de délit tout les groupes
différents groupes peu importe les
hommes blancs les amours les gays
lesbiennes trans
les parties sont pros sont les
féministes c'est pas un monolithe
c'est ce que tout le monde a le même but
dans la vie mais pas la même façon accès
l'écran on peut parler aussi dire que
les péquistes madame tout le monde qui
font ce qu'ils veulent à l'aspiration au
québec manalich
tout le monde veut avoir avoir quelques
la valeur du québec soient vus mais cela
valait vous mises à la vente ces bons
est pas tout le monde qui a la même
façon d'accéder exacte et puis
malheureusement c'est ceux qui crient
plus fort qu'on entend faire à fond face
à ces personnes le son dont transphobes
6 6 6 8 à partir de quelque chose qui
était pas mais ça va sont les pignons de
quelqu'un c'est comme un prêt qu'en
transit sur l'autoroute 30 au t6 qui
sont vraiment là puisqu'en plus de 14,6
des voix la mare en quoi est ce un peu
près la même chose qui arrive fait ses
ravages une carapace
t'as pas le choix j'ai besoin de repos
si je me plains pas ma position parce
qu'à la fin de la journée je fume août
monsieur mila c'est moi qui qui qui me
ce qui m'a mis de l'avant pour que ça
vient avec
pour aller avec mais je constate faut
qu'on en parle parce que dans sa grande
angoisse que j ai beaucoup de tabous
dans l'est comme dans le country des
communautés racisées les communautés
ethniques et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de tabous en parle pas de sexe
en pas de sexualité on parle pas de mon
papa de deux maladies mentales
ok
beaucoup moins que je pense d'un répit
seulement tout seul tout au tout fake
mois pour je parle c'est moi je suis
quand même dans ma carrière ici vit
entourée de gens m'en communauté c'est
une chose qui qui qui récurrent dans la
remontée le pape peut pas parler de tout
et de la pop
ouais c'est un truc qui revient souvent
fait
mouais dans ma famille on avait alors
parlé de beaucoup de choses mais sans
histoire si je sortais de ma famille
vraiment pas c'est fait je un peu casser
ce cercle et le fait quoi et je vois
parler de tout ce qui a parlé ça va être
raf
on n'a pas tout le temps raison on va
parler au moins qu'il ya une conversion
la pointe derrière le site de l'arsenal
de voix qui est paru le printemps c'est
l'importance de crever l'abcès droit et
comment ce qu'on fait c'est vraiment ce
qu'on fait en dix ans ce sera pas pour
lui mais pour soulager le mal qui leur
faut qu'on en parle
faux faux faux foot j'aime
particulièrement
on dirait que pour vous on a parlé on à
fleurs un peu ça mais on dirait que
c'est une jarre de formation continue ou
est ce que comme tu apprends un sujet
politique et pourquoi est-ce que c'est
tabou pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle
pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on a peur de
s'aventurer là d'un plan à travers la
vidéo à travers le raisonnement 30 ans
on voit que vous avancez voir quelque
chose td com ou que vous l'avez fait ce
travail là de rock et pourquoi et puis
essayons d'établir ensemble comment on
peut en parler
ouais ouais ouais mais seppi j'apprends
mousse avec l'effet de pau être capable
de poser la question c'est qu'un blanc
viennent me voir et me disent oui
pourquoi sûr possible mon [ __ ] un
bateau droit de poser la question
c'est personnes imposé en partant quoi
cette vie bien commencé youpi de cette
conversation
personne n'a envie bien je t'avais 6,8
le lui au repos temporairement compris
quoi que ce soit puis toi tu vas avoir
donné aucune information ne tenait pas
voir tu avais l'occasion de donner
l'information quelqu'un le temps
montrera qu'on garde ses 5 ta cause de
ça ce sont les gens vont faire comme on
monte en 2019 ont dans le même temps je
peux pas croire car demain fabrice 3 en
2002 ont été engrangés en 2010 accor qui
en 2002 avait tellement la fin la série
gaston therrien propres à la cia y en
ait encore des gens qui se parlent
encore de l'islam âge là qu'ils se
parlent se fit date de 2009 ne savent
rien dire
bon maintenant sorti j'ai vu que cette
date lève rien fait je cite oui vos
requêtes expliqué que c'était répète se
répète ce que j'appelle les choses c'est
parce que c'est pas ces points sera fait
de la bonne façon si tu parles avec des
gens qui quittaient d'avoir battu un bar
à bulles dans leur espèce de ces dans le
respect de réalité sa réalité
puis passez pas parce que moi je suis d
affaires que vous vous allez les vivait
essentiellement fille efficace et sûr
pour tout le monde que c'est comme
évident pour tout le monde sait que
c'est ça le juste l'effet des fois le
crij enfin il s'insurge juste pour
quelqu'un ait posé une question simple
mais comment est-ce que tu veux que les
gens grandissent piscine etc et on la
conversation s'est on a reçues quand le
reçut nicolas où il est connu que le
wind animateurs sociaux oui c'est qu'on
a eu le débat justement sur tic kendrick
lamar fait monter et blanches sur ce
qu'est la rapidité parole avec les and
the what i du mot d'adieu
c'était le piéger loti il le mit lazare
dans un ravin dans un guet-apens qui est
tombé dedans pc l'espagne etc puis mais
le débat qui a suivi est vraiment
intéressante parce que lui c'est parce
que le chemin il m'a expliqué où il me
donnait son point de vue sur la raison
pourquoi tu utilises poste mieux en
étant blancs sont pas légitimes tant de
lui
tapas choix d'écouter le titre peugeot
de droit peut être d'accord mais t'es
pas jeter tout cas pas chouette d'écouté
de répit
baptisé forte fécondité mais c'est merci
de pouvoir parler - c'est ça d'avoir
rendu ces bons parlé mais tout le monde
parfaitement discussions le foot je
laisse la place aux autres a pas parlé
mais si tu vas voir de quoi qui flottait
une conversation faut quand même qu'on
sait c'est faux quand même pas avoir
peur d'exprimer son opinion même si
techniquement pas la légitimité de la
faune c'est dans une conversation avec
quelqu'un qui connaît un sujet précis x
ou y le mettons comme moi mettons le
sujet par là une femme qui féministe le
pic est clairement son point de vue à
elle sûrement plus réfléchie que le mien
par rapport à cause des femmes mais j'ai
quand même une opinion si j'ai quand
même des opinions ne faut pas juste
litter j'ai l'impression sinon ça crée
pas de dialogues pourquoi faut pas
lutter mais non seulement je dire c'est
pas parce que la personne n'est pas
parce que c'est pas parce que noir que
je disais pillon plus réfléchi sur le
racisme ça c'est pas vrai non non ok les
afin d'arrêter l'expérience d'abord vécu
de l'expérience mais j'ai pas la vérité
non ce ne sera posée que chez exactement
comme on dit et moi qui vit avec moi qui
vis des constructions partout dans
montréal ne fait pas de moi un expert en
construction
je vais pas parce que j'ai subi que je
de vie automatiquement
je sais qu est ce qui se passe comment
les nommer be qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui en
résulte c'est pas exactement comme ça
ça fonctionne j'écris je peux je peux
plus être victime de brutalités
policières ça fait pas de moi un expert
en brutalité policière
j'ai subi le jeu c'est ça l'expérience
j'ai l'expérience mais ça veut dire que
je peux
j pour l'autre côté de la médaille pour
tous pour voir qu'est ce qui se passe
diablo peut-être te donne un peu ton
expérience personnelle attendrait tatum
tabac le tableau complet de ce qui fait
qu'une fois avoir nécessairement une
pensée réfléchie j'ai une pensée j'aime
à penser même appareil est biaisé par
momo mon vécu je crois pas parce qu'il
faut avoir une bonne discussion exemple
j'ai un exemple soit avec ce qui se
passe avec le hashtag nitoo ouais il ya
beaucoup de façons procédé qui ont
changé dans le dans le travail si je
suis pour ce qui se passe quelque chose
dernièrement ils ont fait une étude dans
le milieu du travail
le budget dont les bureaux et tout 62 %
des hommes veulent pas interagir avec
des femmes seules avec une femme doit
pas être seul et et rage et ils veulent
pas ils veulent pas la raison pourquoi
plus de voir des femmes faire campagne
je comprends pas pourquoi qu'est ce qui
se passe tout juste à porter fruit
puisque va être correct puis sipa est
intéressant car on part de m pour ta
légation camp
si on explique c'est quoi il fausse
allégation le lit terne l'ondh dans un
moment de transition le les termes
changent qui englobe plus d'un bios 200
fausses allégations c'est quelqu'un qui
voulait qu'ils voulaient mans series vrt
renard fait ce pari mais pour s'aligner
à sont maintenant ces postes soient
nécessairement ce que maintenant si d'un
milieu de travail
quelqu'un qui m'accuse d'avoir fait
quelque chose on va pas se baser sur les
faits on va seulement se baser commente
la personne ouais
tu as juste je dis pas que c'est
palestine france a placé santé sauf que
c'est peut-être pas décemment les faits
s'étaient pas nécessairement l'intention
d'étendre sa fille était compris je veux
moi je marche dans la rue
merci je marche dans la rue puis j'ai de
l'air dans le gars qui fâchent et ouais
bon je suis pas sûre d'en face j'ai de
la haine
jj d'heure en crise comprend c'est pas
l'intention qui en arrière c'est ce que
les autres gens vont avoir perçu excuse
moi je marche il faut que je suis
consciente qu est-ce que j'ai de la six
mois je marche dans la rue est un homme
noir déjà là on est déjà plus menaçants
selon l'opinion publique avec la face
que j'ai je vais faire arrêter plus par
la police parce qu'ils voient passer que
je m'en occupe pas faire exclure examen
dans un comté c'est vraiment parce que
je mange on est tranquille dans un
contexte de travail la même chose peut
arriver et ça ça de vie ça peut donner
un forçat l'aviation maintenant une
femme s'est sentie mal à l'aise une
situation est ce qu'il y avait
nécessairement la matière première base
doit l'interpréter quelque chose pour
moi en tant qu'homme 6e juste une
allégation de sun soit pas allé de
travers si fine il s'approche de radio j
sans doute pour que le monde se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe est faux faut en
parler de se [ __ ] capable d'en parler
faut pas être comme oui mais le nom
c'est une réalité qu'on vit en tant
qu'homme il ya aussi ce côté là aussi il
faut comprendre qu'on fait raison sauf
que si je peux regarder ma soif d'en
parler mais j'en parlais pas des je le
sais ça ça a changé les termes fossat
les gaz c'est plus la confiance mais
c'est ça on en parle on peut savoir
qu'on peut voir si ces six nuances là
dans le monde ça crée une situation qui
sont ces mettons le lien exemple qui me
vient en tête des crises ces mets ton si
l'humoriste à 10 ans arrivant c'est
quelqu'un arctique anonymes qui soit
celui d'une femme qui après une soirée
avec lui mais dès qu'elle peut passer
une bonne soirée
puis elle pas aimé la manière qu'ils ont
quelques chansons qui l a dit plus j'en
parle à de monde tout le monde me disent
que si négation sexuelle tulle il truc
qui déjà en plus de par la lunette de
2,2 sanitaire le met à elle fait pour la
version qui dit c'est moi
et c'est tellement touch et d'un
personnel mais c'est mai mais samsung
affaire c'est que vous ne regardiez son
témoignage vaut un témoin si son
témoignage ce qu'ils aiment raconte elle
me dit que c'est pas une agression
j'ai même pas une pose la question à
looberghe de l'aube à ce que tu me
racontes attendu en tant que victime et
pas une agression puissant une vision
but savoir les filles vous aimez tout le
monde doit savoir listing des signes de
m
carmen a soupé je te fais je te fais je
commande les huîtres qui est un aliment
aphrodisiaques
je paye le 20 je m'en vais te lis des
deux côtés on délire d'avancé tout le
monde à quelqu'un de lire des films
quand on dessine on peut répondre à ces
gâté ou si tu peux apprendre ce qui à
tout moment n'empêche que tu peux
retirer
peut être dans la soirée plus rendu chez
eux rendus à n'importe quel moment tu
peux dire puis danny way facture
peut-être qu'à manille à un moment ou à
ski est là s'est sentie puis down
pilote- le pauvre vu le pôle lui c'est
ce événements complexes question le bon
c'est complexe mais ce qui est si je
peux pas en parler non c'est un homme
non les gars le design apparaît même
vous fait pas le titre pop parler ça me
gâche un peu le sunny side space sont
pas des six pays c'est la façon ça
fonctionne c'est que tcc des cercles ses
dessertes différents cercles savants de
broc cercle vert que mon petit sac à
l'intérieur c'est le plus gros secteur
extérieur puis c'est tout
des cercles qui donne raison à l'état
d'alors de l'autre puis plus de l'éphèbe
cercle puisque pas parlé avec le monde
sort à l'intérieur c'est juste mon alter
obsèques qui peuvent faire leurs
extérieurs l'extérieur l'extérieur le
plus gros cercle et ça c'est les hommes
blancs après ça que les femmes blanches
après ça te
une personne
gay lesbienne d'entre ans après c'est un
homme ou un homme noir pas moi le plus
petit cirque à l'intérieur si une femme
trans mi6 noah handicapés et aveugle oui
ces personnes ne plus parler à tout le
monde et les flyers mais tous ne pouvait
parler se comprend ces programmes sont
une conversation sait pas plus mais de
l'avis cap sur un pied d'égalité
personne ne fait pas partie de la
conversation
ben ça m'affecte oui oui fait passer la
conversation je peux pas un effondrement
de donner mon opinion ou imposer quelque
chose
la même façon qu'ils quittèrent pour
l'imposer mais je peux parler de comment
je me sens avec ce petit monde feutré
conversation petit moment que t'es pas
un truc eu des manques et et informent
nos actes et empathique si je pourrai
jamais je n'aurais jamais noir sèchera
jamais non jamais dit que l'expérience
est noir je peux avoir une opinion sur
le racisme en général peu ce qui se
passe c'est que j'ai l'impression
surtout ici que des perspectives qui
sont qui sont sur dit qu'ils sont
surexposés l'été je demande à danseurs
de ski ce que tu dis je suis d'accord
avec toi de déduire tout le monde
devrait avoir accès à participer aux
conversations mais c'est juste que j'ai
l'impression la perspective de l'homme
blanc hétérosexuel privilégié que met-on
moi je peux avoir j'ai l'impression qui
a déjà été dit plusieurs fois this way m
pas de réponse
qu'est ce que c'est qu'il faut le
laisser les autres parler ouais mais
faut voir si la conversation en tirer
c'est que pendant toutes ces années là
c'est l'homme blanc qui parler en la
maintenant on va voir une conversation
sport en faisant semblant de fermer sa
gueule puis par lille à dijon fco qui
les mettront à l'essai cette personne
n'a parlé mais si vous pour répliquer
houssin forte le dialogue c'est un
dialogue qu'on cherche à revoir pour
l'espèce de dictateur de l'opposé le
suspense si si on vous fait un gros
problèmes qu'hypo mieux que s'il n'y a
pas de dépôt de bilan
on prend oui pendant terminé le lin
blanc a eu la parole sauf que si vous
rétablir suspens faisant balancy
balancer la chose c'est pas en ayant
suppose que les hommes aient peu droit
toutes les femmes et tous les droits le
fait le contraire le problème si l'être
humain il faut se passe pas si il va se
passer d'aidé dit la même chose qui se
passe devant demain ça sera la même
chose
c'est en ayant la conversation en
donnant la parole aux femmes et en ayant
cette conversation là en permettant que
les femmes et les hommes plus se parler
on maquille d'égalité sur le sujet
peut-être les hommes je serai petit que
les femmes plus très bien porter leurs
points des problèmes se maintient la
pression qu'on a atteint le ballon où
est ce que l'autre le côté opprimés
finalement a pris le pouvoir
non non non les parents n'osent pas
mieux comme en mer malgré les pharaons
ont dit on n'est vraiment pas là sauf
que toutes les personnes qui sont comme
entraîneur comme son temps de parler
fort comment ouais les conversations va
convaincre personne en est un j'ai
d'abord conversation galant qui rejoint
directement règle non le yoyo absolument
pas un conflit comme ça de façon c'est m
ce qu'on prend quelqu'un qui est juste
rentrer ensemble sera d'y aller tout le
monde qu'en laissant qu'un personne n'a
vraiment compris ce qui s'est passé on
peut en parler on peut pas pourquoi elle
lève les mort qu'est ce qui se passe je
veux c'est ça c'est ça la fin
ou est ce que il faut qu'on se barre en
même temps je comprends pas ce qu'il y
en a qui ont des écrans très tôt les
projets de loi est fort chez kant et
opprimés absolument sauf que justement
de cette attitude le hamas serait pas la
bonne même si des fois c'est ce que tu
en as envie de faire du droit d'être
fâché de droit d'être fasciste plus
triton points sauf que la personne je
les fait la personne n'écoutera pas soit
parce que les gens ont droit d'échangé
il ya une raison d'être fâché dans le
droit sauf que quand s'y cassent le
temps d'exprimer ton point et de devons
trouver une solution
gueuler après quelqu'un t'a forme ce
beau monde
jean michel javaux excellente démarche
tu as tout dit si je parle avec une
féminine ce qui n'est vraiment mieux son
sujet je le dois à mon opinion quand
même si les deux personnes ccoty si l
ate explique que ces arguments sont
solides sont fondées sont basées sur les
faits qui tout est ouvert d'esprit
je pense très sincèrement que la raison
convaincu si c'est à manier aussi dans
l'éduction émerge la ville
c'est clair une affaire qui m'est venue
en tête ça fait quand même un bout que
les gens qui sont
appelons ça au maroc les gens qui sont
pour l'égalité de tout le monde ça fait
quand un bout que cette idée là de dire
on va pas exagérer le balan dans l'autre
bord si on veut juste viser l'égalité
ça fait un bout que cette pensée là
existe mais que au final ça se passe
comme paul cézanne se passe comme pas de
réussir à atteindre cette égalité le à
cause de plaintes personnes qui ont pas
au site
cette mentalité là encore qui n'ont pas
encore changé leur façon de voir les les
inégalités métier ça fait un bout qu'on
connaissait en tant que société que les
femmes soient sur un pied d'égalité avec
les hommes s'est pas encore arrivé à
quel moment est ce qu'on se dit on garde
cette technique lotis on garde la
technique de dire tu es con vas pas
exagérer on veut juste atteindre
l'égalité plus finalement tu arrives
puis ça tamponne mesbah qu'on veut pas
exagérer je veux atteindre l'égalité
le transfert de l'eau côté il faut une
lutte continuelle c'est une lutte
continue et ça va pas se régler comme
celle ci mettra maintenant je prends les
gars l'artiste les os qui c'était juste
des blancs qui avait été nominé ses
juges et blanc j'ai l'impression que
pour réussir à dire ok on va on va
ouvrir la porte pour que tout le monde
avait des opportunités égales dans ce
milieu là j'ai l'impression qu'à ramener
aux frères dire ok tchèque on octroie
plus de positions à des gens de
différentes nîmes ainsi que faire trop
non je pense pas qu'on va se rendre le
jeu c'est à cause de nos problèmes
ça fait la discrimination envers des
beaux jeux sociaux - il lancé dans un
range au poids est engagé pour l'un je
peux être engagées pour la même raison
le repos est engagé je pourrais je pas
est une coche dans une boîte
ok
on a le noir de chez un chef autochtone
ouais d'accord j'ai comprendre que je
peux être un check back
admettons que quelques personnes qui
sont des tchèques box pour 1 5 10 ans
puis éventuellement le paysage
médiatique change complètement puisque
l'autre réussi à avoir beaucoup de
diversité
ça va faire que probablement des jeunes
de différentes de différentes cultures
vont vouloir aller dans ce milieu là
puis éventuellement seront plus des
tchèques bozza phare du gala c'est pas
populaire comme façon penser on pense
aux tec raté mon suis je plus demandés
je pus fabas a aucun projet pour la
diversité jean japon a demandé que la
diversité ne joue pas pour que je veux
pas c'est juste que j'allais dans ma
communauté
je ferai du monde que moi je peux faire
je veux créer mes plates formes gens
encourager des gens comme moi dans ma
communauté a créé une plateforme pias
formés parce que oui on peut chienlit
sur le gala artis qui ont pesé
yo yo pa ya pas de potes là-bas mais à
la fin de la journée
dans ma communauté
les ors et les spectacles c'est pas au
clae pareil pour les enfants mais à
cause ou tu es aussi à cause que des
modèles si je lui dis je dans les
articles le mans qui est qui va lui
dernièrement sur aux autres tu disais
que c'est le seul modèle quand j'étais
jeune c'était anthony kavanagh sinon
écouter ce qui se faisait au stade c'est
que toucher arrière parce que sinon tu
te connaissait pas nos portes
fax normal aussi que les parents disent
qu'ils n'ont stent est un petit gaulois
au québec
dispo allant d'un média tu prendras ta
vie tu vas réussir tout va gagner n'a
rien manqué et russie sont faites en
faisant ma plateforme wat il le fait moi
j'ai pas fait comme hey données - donnez
donnez moi mais je suis d'accord que
d'attendre ne pas attendre après
personnes
c'est la meilleure façon c'est la
meilleure façon de faire le cyclone earl
tout à persévérer quand même dubitatif
faux cov même si le système ou même si
y'a plus de modèles font cela
d'appareils mais je peux comprendre mais
si quelqu'un qui fait mais c'est juste
pas possible en même temps je me suis
réveillé à 33 ans comprend s'appellera
pas g37 c'est peut-être mais bon ils
n'ont pas finalement moi je retourne
dans la communauté je vais faire le tri
dans la communauté
avant de commencer on le pose sur
secondaire mais par un bond des
infirmiers infirmières un ingénieur avec
tout seul droit comptable mais pas
pendant ce temps là le petit mathis
tremblay qui est lui qui est en option
théâtre puis faites-les promouvoir ces
paroles pour sa fin de vie
c'est comme changer faut que dans ma
communauté change cette mentalité-là job
que je leur montre qu'il ya différentes
pour le faire savoir que moi evo 6 mai
que si j'ai pas mal commenté ben y en
aura pas plus stressé c'est vraiment une
bonne façon d'atteindre cet objectif
au lieu de demander tout le temps wife
face pour ce faire soit gage
je comprends a pas sûr de moi deux
secondes je reviens mais macrez motifs
ans les enfants le travail que j'ai
besoin de faire dans ma communauté
après ça quand que je crie misère foire
à ma communauté de montbard comme est
intéressante
l'airé peuple les époques jamais fait
comme s il vous plaît jouez nous non ils
ont fait leur truc dans la remontée en
fait leur pari l'intrus compris les
leurs dans ce long trailer langage loire
tout musulman ce matin titré pub de ce
versement en fait comme une fille cool
on devrait les engagés on a une
expertise vient m'engager parce que je
fais quelque chose de construit quelque
chose de différent presse
c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse comme ça
déjà marché c'est devenu le mouvement la
musique le pays dans le monde ont pas de
réponse a déjà été le rock le roi
devient des doses de cette mentalité là
à le voir c'est déjà la musique n'est
plus aussi le monde font leur truc dans
leur comme motif juste faut juste pas de
ségrégation pas fermée à personne se
veut le faire fait là il ya pas de
problème mais d'autres enfin autre puis
après son tour une expertise qui sous de
nouveaux outils pour être exploités
c'est un magnifique m'enfin ce qui se
passe dans ce cercle est loin ces
attaques ne cessent pas en faisant genre
hey nous autres on veut autant je
savoure ce propos les medias je pense
pas que ça va fonctionner comme ça ne va
pas fonctionner comme ça le message
passe pas par la fin de la journée je
vais même si les médias sont à l'image
de montréal la majorité du québec n'est
pas à montréal c'est la réalité de la
chose c'est sûr que les gens sont allés
faire de montréal vont voter pour le
monde qui leur ressemble si tu reviens
c'est juste logique je parle pas arrêté
de georges pas demander qui nous inclus
ça va juste faire ce que ces gens là
peau soirée mais des personnes à
l'extérieur forcé des nations mais la
tvq salariale et pas l'image à montréal
la tv ce qui se fait à montréal comme
contenu télévisuel est pas à l'image
maria pas l'image moratti mois mais tant
que j'ai fait pour vendre ailleurs là
sauf que ce qui représente
il montre un peu il montre le montréal
le montréal
ces maisons mojine québec puisqu'elle
j'écoutais la tv des protections fait à
montréal
ouais je me reconnaissent et puis je
dire connaissez ma ville de québec
blanche
si c'est fait pour ça c'est fait c'est
fait pour nous au tempo c'est fait c'est
fait à montréal
mais quand maintenant mais nantes
habitat montréal pizza toute la
diversité qui eux c'est parce qu'ils ont
une vision à terminaison s'appelle quand
même d'urgence dans un hôpital royal
tout le staff et blanc tu es comme à
quelle date a été avancée c'est le staff
et blanc ça ne marche pas c'est fait
sauf qu'il l'hôpital est à montréal
c'est fait basé sur un modèle montréal
est fait pour être vendues à l'extérieur
bien peu un effacement des régions la
danse il ya je suis venue au wat michaud
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment tout
d'abord puis est ce qui s'appelait sur
la philosophie justement derrière
lorsqu'on parlait de créer quelque chose
parce que c'est justement quand je pense
à l'image de montréal hier c'était une
soirée à l'image de mon frère tu avais
dit maurice francophones anglophones
démarche francophones ne dit mot en
anglais
les photos liens vers des photos inverse
tu avais différentes couleurs différence
c'est le 30 août
tout le monde a même place tout le monde
connecté sa maman s'est fait reprendre
il y est c'est fait un beau trophée
c'est chaud le ca enfin deux en deux ans
qu'on fait ce choix qu'ont fait ces
trucs le gse avec le monde que je
connais avec le monde le montréal qui
est scanné et puis on a fait d'autres
qu'on fait nos trucs on se concentre en
amont enfin il ya qui est arrivé cet été
j'espère et je cherchais en fait quand
même oui oui on peut aimer gisements
gaziers du monde que j'ai du monde qui
montre un paquet conseil que j'ai fait
mon temps précieux qui le monde qui me
ressemble
qu'ils ne représentent en fait un joueur
français vers l'anglais parce que c'est
ce qu'on fait ce qu on est en étant
autant fier du français que d'en faire
des anglais connecter ces deux ces deux
solitudes le sait cependant tout le
monde a compris tout le monde rit aux
mêmes places
enfin peu importe s'il ne quittait plus
francophone puisque iphone sénat qui
tenait différents background cuadrilla
même coincé sur la fin en fait six pas
en demandant à des sports et ayoub une
place et on veut le planant vous
enfermer enfants se fermer à faire le
jeu parfait chose que d'ailleurs je n'ai
pas fini de faire travailler enfin être
fini je suis vraiment à prendre c'est
pas longtemps que je fais ça fait 4 x 4
a en tout deux ans à temps plein est
fait que j'ai beaucoup de croûtes à
manger
j beaucoup de choses et j'ai beaucoup de
choses à apprendre pour trouver à manger
beaucoup de le faire de montbard
ces gens là vont chercher c'est un
article
cette espèce de droit et on a devant
être clos mais ça c'est le genre de
fraude tech que tu dit en entrevue qui
est cité qui vont être déformés
complètement ouais mais que quand lot
est là devant moi tu me l'expliquer aux
choristes ouais ça fait tout le sens du
monde est déjà une espèce de de blog
blog un peu disons un peu de droit puis
taupe y compris mon propos guéri fait
que j'ai cette formule et ou par lequel
elle était comme way au galop dynasties
qui ont des fourmis mon propre au pot
farcie les enfants mais c'est exactement
déformer mes propos quand je parlais
justement
deux des gens qui veulent imposer que
j'aime une affaire où 90 des portes à
déformer mes propos je pensais que je
suis con la vie de ces personnes de ses
personnages sans réserve aux mois pas un
sandwich au deuxième passage auprès de
fasciste en mangeant l'existence des
cendres et se doit être l'oeil à votre
problème mais moi je ne mange pas de ce
pain et y'a pas de problème pour ce
malin pose pas ceci est une préférence
mais pas de problème
[Musique]
comprendre que les gens on prend ton
propos puis le déformer parce qu'ils
vont penser pas avec les lol la logique
même animation sexy vampire
puis je veut abolir les scènes de choses
exactement qu'ils avaient pris de non je
trouve ça dégueulasse 9,9 et condé de
poule construit à science est ce que
soit l'information que je t'aime ma
blonde amènerait mouillé non c'est quand
même une bonne omelette de monstre
annonçée la battante au biberon ou mais
tout ça c'est des gens vont le garder il
est traité l'animal
ce n'est pas moi je me garde jeune homme
la prochaine fois je me cale mangé une
humble rdc se sentant sauvage sur ce
même argent en abris while ball et ça
laisse groupe b ouais ouais c'est comme
ça que mon cerveau fonctionne au total
bon c'est bon dirigeant oui les gens ont
des formes électriques vont y aller avec
l'animation et tout le réseau qui
[Musique]
souhaiteraient qui vanessa pilote
ménagement par l'appareil
j'aime bien ce qui au fait qu'elle est
là le discours de beaucoup de personnes
et perdre a dit m qui vous fait sauf que
défaut des dérapages téléphonique miser
jeunes qu'est ce que vous avez fait en
vidéo ce qu'il vous a parlé de la 10e
nation sont grandes que ce musée de la
danse ferrer 6-2 6-1 l'espace a fait des
heat en relisant des âmes mobster qu'est
ce que me âgées un doigt mais si c'est
comme ça le regarde une discrimination
envers les hommes de petite taille ceci
j'ai fait tout ce qu'on vit là dedans
c'est que c'est superficiel la farce
même en défense parsienne qu'on voit ça
l'avouer mais les hommes sont ce père
s'est aussi vu égal on est une société
qui gère ciel superficiel c'est juste
qu'on est superficiel sur d'autres
choses mais soyons justes d'accord pour
dire que
bâché quelques jours sa grandeur c'est
super ciel le nom de call soudainement
tout le monde convient que je promets je
mesure vrai qu'en partant parce que
c'est un enjeu c'est super ciel tard
façon si je te demandais combien tu
passes
ouais fille superficielle ces
différentes choses mais c'est
superficiel sa règle c'est que c'est
quoi ton vrac c'est quoi c'était trop
brave super fils soit on est d'accord
pour dire que les hommes et les femmes
sont superficielles pour différentes
choses lorsque j'y vais c'est comme les
je vous ai mis sur le même pied
d'égalité
je ne sais pas si pomme mise à gênes
j'ai mis les hommes et les femmes sur le
même pied d'égalité
ceux-ci du féminin semaine cet accord
montre que les deux on est pareil là
dessus qu'est ce qui amusait de la dent
mais j'ai expliqué mon point de vue elle
est faite comme l om et défaut les
commentaires cas par cas quand on
regarde vos commentaires cette région
alors qu'il les gens commandent c'est
nous on est garant méga notamment le
mois lemoine au discours de misogyne moi
j'ai vite quand on me pose la question
de comment que je dis là avec les gens
qui m'insultent est ouvertement sur
facebook
j répondu ben c'est juste des
commentaires fitou ouais c'est jean
longue droite pourrait d'accord avec est
requise et mazouté wever mais si on
porte un endroit qui ajoute que ce soit
d'accord avec moi ou pas d'accord avec
moi ça reste des commentaires de droit
pareil
le ces gens là le canton n'était pas
d'accord avec moi sont mises en jeu des
commentaires quand son musée jeune fille
d'érable c'est encore juste des
commentaires
j'ai pas changer mon premier métier
n'était pas plus capable de le dire ou
es ce que je te disais jeune je veux
dire que cette personne elle est basée
sur son feeling son émotion pour déraper
toi ce que tu fais face à falla même
chemin de fer exact de raser sûreté
feeling pourvu que moi rejeter la faute
est très proche de cette personne là
j'ai fait rentrer les jeunes tard façon
de penser et donc cerveau et wired la
même façon cette personne
jusque vais pas les mêmes les mêmes
visions adultes avec un peu de bol on
est allé l'oeuvre française
je pose une question était plutôt en
parler des 30 d'être est une personne
trans la réponse est non
mettons le vous demandez à des femmes
d'être éteint au petit doigt la réponse
est non s il n'y a pas quelque chose de
similaire dans ces deux situations au
sénat c'est les hommes et les femmes
sont un certain point sépare superficie
avait pas j'ai une affection
j'ai une affection pour un seul ps le
nier j'ai je la denrée diriez-vous t je
le sais que je joue vraiment bien passé
mais se prend pour des techniques non
sollicitée mais je trouve vraiment
vaincre l'ennemi il ça s'arrête on
comprend ce que je des prêts une femme
sur un pénis non parce que c'est ça
j'aime beaucoup plus les vagins bon rica
mais quand vous dites qu'en fait les
vidéos mettant serait que les femmes
font du rdmc est ce que c'est un constat
ou une critique sans construire 50 de
l'actif et juste pour rire et on nie
toute partielle
c'est juste ça soit en jeu d'accord en
ce très grand bain d'eau et on est juste
super ciel que les jeunes que je te
demande ton bâton fois que tu me demande
ma grandeur c'est superficiel on est
pareil mais je pense que je pense que la
critique vient de dire que c'est
hypocrite de
reproché la même chose si oui c'est
comme même si c'est un constat le
constat en tant que tel fait une
critique de diaw est elle a arrêté de
nous dire que nous ayons une spéciale
parce qu'on dit on veut pas dtx ou y
personnes alors que vous tout le monde
écoute sur tmz je me rappelle quand
j'étais sur tender c'était une des
premières questions que surya tout le
temps ce que tu me convient nous offrons
bien d'ailleurs combien carré du
cinquième match
ghost var étaient trop petits points pas
de réponse pas s'arrêter
chacun son truc pour exactement j'ai pas
l'attendre encore ok j'avoue les 10e et
j'ai continué le cepd et des critères
façon qu'une personne trans regardé
comme acquis des prix des pièces
ok elle va consommer c'est qu'ici je te
dis maintenant moi je n'étais pas une
fille noire sinon le racisme et pourquoi
tu es si c'est si si korek devoir
protéger son héritage
je comprends ce n'est pas nécessairement
ce pas contre c'est pas parce que tu
poses je sortirai griffes des filles
blanc avec les yeux
c'est pas parce que tu es pauvre c'est
comme exemple j'ai un constat comme ça
tv5 sa tête rosa chez moi ta force à une
fée qui avaient des préjugés qui venait
qui venait je n'ai pas trop joué avec
moi puis elle elle dit moi je suis
blonde aux yeux bleus j'aimerais ça que
mes enfants soient blondes aux yeux
bleus comme acquis sékou ben moi
j'aimerais c'est que bizarrement 60 et
parce que c'est pour un demi critères et
ses collègues lorsque sa raison à elle
parce qu'elle aimait pas les noirs c'est
une différence on sait qu elle l avait
clairement cet astre il est fait
qu'est-ce que pour ça c'est parce que tu
veux préserver et dz je vais vous une
préférence une préférence de quoi que ce
soit pour moi fait mais je peux si c'est
superficiel parent avec un jeu parfait
là je me mets dans l'os
je comprends ce que tu es là dedans si
on nie tout là dedans j'peux meilleur
que quelqu'un d'autre ne veut pas à vous
les paysans vous faire superficielle moi
je suis ma culotte c'est spécial mais
légitime dans le fond avec cette affaire
et je prends moi occupé toi sur le post
pourquoi est-ce que je m'arrangerais
fiche plus d'un ainsi essayer de preuve
que tout le monde même comprends je peux
pas je peux pas faire ça même si je fais
de l'humour c'est ma job
ben ils osent monde vont détester ce que
je fais ici correct qui pourrait être
dans le monde
la mangue la juteuse et sucrée au monde
il ya toujours du monde qui vont
détester les manques tu peux rien pour
ça peut être une thème les femmes hors
baie voisine se poser à bollywood si je
pose est est ce la fin c'est pas parce
que je veux pas une affaire que je veux
la mort ou l'ablation si le retrait de
tout ça six postes c'est qu'avec ton
émotions je pense que c'est ça parce que
souvent dans la vie ce qui vient avec un
c quand un point de choses tu peux
l'enlever
le cpo si je choisis eux pour françois
simard pas là manquent pas ce que tu
penses qu'ils étaient membres sont
empoisonnés ou cet été neuf fois et
malgré ce site
exactement c'est pourquoi c'est quoi une
preuve concrète que temp aliments ou
exterminer tout démenti tout ce que
c'est quoi avec ce beau monde est ce qu
il se trouve que tu manques tant
souffrir c'est un composé par exemple on
voit quoi on parle
las vegas est il sorti son camp par deux
semaines
dernier la convaincre chauffe contre x
déposée était capable en madame je ne
savais pas qu'on a pensé à dépenser quoi
en fait quoi ces petits plus dit que
juste avoir discuté dit et comme sont
offerts un autre parallèle le monde
indique m
quelqu'un qui dit le moule avec
africaine joué que ça mais c'est dans le
temps ça me dérangeait clan blanc dise
je m'en fous je ne sois pas reçu de
bannir un bon mois celle là mais
celle-là je suis pas convaincu bon c'est
pourquoi alors parce que c'est pas dans
ton avantage d'être convaincu ok parce
que dès qu'on a des conséquences à toi
qui dis semoule décision qui était pas
convaincu
est ce que tu ne vois pas aucune
conséquence que je dis qu'est ce que je
faisais était pourtant des études qu'il
faut bannir le mot
leurs noms n'ont malheureusement dans le
langage courant
toi ya des conséquences à moyen en
apport dans l'axé sur lequel mon embolie
qu il comprend mais qu'est ce que je
veux dire où est ce que je suis pas
convaincu c'était vraiment à l'histoire
de kendrick lé ouais c'est donc
maintenant moi je veu râpé une tonne
parce que j'aime la toune j'aime
l'artiste je veux rappeler les paroles
puis je dois le flou vauvy calmes et
amener tous les côtes la tonne puis tout
le fait conditionné jeu pas convaincu
quand on étudie à qu'aymen ce gentil
seul le faut que tu changes les paroles
mais je peux je le poids la phase de jeu
le poids qu'on s'arrête à la
signification danse où je peux concevoir
contrat s'arrête au mot je veux qu'on
s'arrête aux comptes séparés
y'a du second la fête qui comme ça s'est
passé
maintenant c'est à dire l extrait un
extrait sur youtube vous serez choqués
c'est un jean luc mongrain alors les
gens lui une de ses fameuses montée de
lait oui oui c'est fameuse montée de
l'udc et ça commence par là qu'une dame
la dame du 10 sport à 6 mai m
aucun mot kitsch rigueur aucun mot
déclenché puis est pas raciste mais tout
ce qui est vie
le compte n a qu est ce qu a dit fait
très raciste mais la boîte bon
techniquement et le petit cheveu
jean-luc lui défend la cause et vivre
mon deuil et d'amour mais ces politiques
racistes le faucon faut pas consommer il
ya vu mon avis mon arrêt de l'écouté
nouveau faux pas de ces mots là n'est
pas correct quand il faut arrêter de
fond de jeu s'arrête au mont faut aller
avec le contexte de la chose qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient quelque part en asie
français trois listes orientation c'est
pas juste ce n'est pas juste c'est pas
juste un mot le seuil en compte est
juste bannir le mot fin comme non vous
êtes trop de ça s'est très mal passé
pour ce qu'est ce qui arrive que je fais
juste 0.02 au saumon la semoule semoule
au saumon la belle affaire qui arrive
que les gens naviguent entre la valeur
dans notre champ jamais dit en somme où
leur nom mais qui avait filmé notre
chambre de raciste
concrètement tu peux pas de vecchi
raciste parce qu'il y avait aucun shsh
l'horreur mais quand même si le deal
n'est pas au but et même peut obliger de
ces mots là pour être raciste il tire
ses moules et pas être raciste n'a un
bon mois un égal paulo train va pas dans
l'autre contre ans parce que mon jeu
comme non munch pause ça me dérange pas
moins qu'il a fait sauf que c'est le
fils à jo chaude kendrick lamar
attributs 100 artistes noirs est
vraiment bien plus de noirs et blancs
d'accord le obtenez serment qu'elle ne
changerait pas son match et lopy
attribue sa culture et sa musique puis à
mons où siègent pour chanter la saturn
préféré adopter que moi ce que je veux
c'est que les blancs justement l'heure
parce que beaucoup plus que moi
moi ça me dérange pas je te conseillerai
pas déjà pas de wasit parce que moi je
pense comme ça c'est moi je pointais
exactement malinois ne sont pas un
monolithe
on vient là dessus mais oui moi ça me
dérange pas meilleure
l'un au passif à dire en fait je
confierais pas dire ça mon lait partout
sauf que moi je vois j delà de la 2 qui
fit pas le contexte ne se contentent
tout qu'est ce qui est évident c'est que
croisic quoi le contexte la chose tu es
bien qu'il dise mot là c'est une chose
quelqu'un qui dit avant notre ère comme
des [ __ ] c'est autre chose s'ils
croient qu'ils vont harceler
parce que oui c'est sa fille croit le
compte hélas parce que le jury comptait
il ya les expressions conquis qui était
courante au québec quitté racisme c'est
une contexte qu'est la personne comment
que je vais dire d'où tu irais pas ce
qui était dû à eux
bagis a été conscient petits chevaux et
et je voyais expliqué passer encore là
pour moi
2009 c'est pas un instit référence le
playbook et city d'ici dix ans on encore
mais enfin on a encore des enfants et
des rivières petit lac farc ep encore
rivières on est étonné d'entendre ce que
je pourrais je pas pour ça ça fait
partie
ce que je suis pour ce côté je me dis
dont mais ça fait aussi partie du mas du
patrimoine fait partie de l'histoire
c'est ça fait partie d'un rappel tu
enlève tout seul tu es dans quelques
générations le montant s'entend répondre
au populisme et du racisme au québec qc
ca l'invasion cahier des gens qui
pensent que je me d'esclavagé nuit de
son nez face tout seul je veux pas qu'on
les fasse le convoi jockey sa phase
parti c'est comme se moquant je me
faisais à la fois ici c'est juste
pointer regarde par cas c'est correct
fou ça fait partie oui c'est comme ça
c'est une question qui qui est
importante
aujourd'hui c'est être l'arrestation si
des premiers ministres racistes qu'on
est au québec ou non et non pour moi
non non on peut changer la plaque
présent on peut changer la plaque enfin
comme cette grande bâtisse ce mail a
aussi fait ce qu ont frappé la longue
ans et je me souviens comment ça
explique tout petit peu on se souviendra
grand chose à se comprendre on te plaît
tellement qu'ils publient dans mon dieu
il ya un mais j'ai chaque année boubou à
chaque année comprend sexy comme tout
effacer ce n'est pas nécessairement pour
tout dire assez qui peut changer la
plaque je peux lui mettre une plaque est
véridique instruit les gens qui passent
par le sais parce que papa pour célébrer
fait mais pour montrer que ça s'est
passé puis on n'oubliera pas que ça
c'est par là et l'on va pouvoir bouger
en fait jusqu'à chez seul se cacher en
dessus et en dessous du tapis trois
marques qu'on a fait on pas à prendre de
force avec l'église catholique fait ça
que le gouvernement fait ça avec tout le
tout au tout les civils et changent la
blague meilleur commence à changer les
seins pour colette les pédos ledentu la
guerre exactement ce que paient les
mêmes à l'un d'eux se trouve à quelque
chose ce serait réellement je me
souviens ah ouais je me suis alors vos
principaux qui t'attend société chez eux
jusqu'au la haye était l'agent kherfi
asseyez-vous les enfants c'est une belle
histoire
laissez moi jamais et oui mais il faut
se souvenir iphone cia nattitude de
certains groupes certaines personnes de
ces gens qui lui n aime pas son opinion
il faut pas qu'ils parlent tell tale
quelque chose que tu arrives dans
l'histoire on n'aime pas ce qu'on les
fasse cesser pour que cette règle est
probable que ce soit la translation des
bains mieux de mettre face à face puis
quatre raisons cadets de bons arguments
c'est pas parce que l'autre si elle doit
parole quatre raisons tu as raison quand
c'est quelque chose mais on part
décelable mais encore leur public un peu
plus pop la jambe gauche moi je sais pas
pour qui quand c'est son show quelqu'un
m'explique pas qu'est ce qui a fait et
vous est à recommencer ce qui a fait de
pas correct
bon quelques ce même temps qu'à nature
fait le même affaire mme hamilton
comprend il comprendra pas déjà pris des
mois et des mois c'est vous parlez vous
bien
ça arrange les affaires sont selon beau
rêve romantique quand celui qui est
juste pour qu'ils n'ont pas droit
top cops pour la plug doit pas exclure
une poésie à leur grille et tu avances
paul ouais ça a été une grosse carapace
histoire mais je trouve que l'issue a
été quand même qui est idéal et puis il
y eut japon sans faute d'accord non j'ai
l'impression qu'ici ils sont vraiment
assis il ya eu des nouvelles versions
moi c'est lui à fait ok je viens juste
pénible qui comme un peu à vide ces
mails en anglais ben non moi j'ai été
censuré
s'ils ont la sensation vraiment rien
compris
de fait la france qu'un kit allaitement
d'apparaître ouais hein
seppi je sais c'est ça moi je les rejets
de la voir quand s'est déclaré à bord
expliqué ça s'arrête ça fait une victime
ça ma façon de grade quasiment aux
pourparlers vont se radier heureusement
elle clairement et est aigri et puis
blessé le cpie mais en même temps ce
tournant par le jetez pas plus convaincu
non plus des arguments de la militante
anti slave qui étaient là non plus pas
très content et inégale des ptt poste
est pas le superbe entrevue le pour moi
je ne restais pas s'étaient pas
présentés par les personnes les plus les
accords plus important et pas seulement
avec son talent et non exactement pour
un truc soit la personne la mieux placée
pour en parler tout et tout donc j'ai
pas trompé sur cet épisode le
de tout le monde en parle mais s'opposer
à ce qui se passe au québec ne t'empêche
pas quel monde en parle et non pas de
parlons peu parlons glisserait scalise
temps le temps n'importe quelle sphère
par le n'importe quel se parle on a
parlé avec judith lucic est venu ici
tipi on parlait de la fois parce que
justement des militants voulant empêcher
une préfère une discussion avec mathieu
bock côté de notre côté nous dit que ça
fait c'est y ait donné dix fois plus de
visibilité actuellement parce que les
italiques pleurer sur toutes les
tribunes tout les journaux de jeu me
fait censurer na nana na na
sinon il réajuste donner cette
conférence devant vingt personnes en
bibliothèque sortir mature burke rôti
aux droits par les wild girls droite
grèce qui a besoin d'air sauf que en
france est lente se fait pas l'enlève
d'addiction fait l'addition erreur avec
plus de force
salle t-rex à lhassa radicalise c'est
clair c'est simple le but le but fait
pas c'est pas de calais le monde c'était
de faire changer les pignons gens
changent pas encore expliquer ce qui se
passe sur netflix le lait chaud dans les
domaines des tic à nier quelques années
et on y tient clairement aidé fois il
délire la semaine mais annie 57
challenge et ce rêve sur tremble sur ses
idéaux politiques puis id hyper comme
ses moyens puis ils évitent le sujet et
c'est sûr que sur cette entrevue laisse
qui dit c'est moi je veux juste que les
gens qui sont pros turin se fasse pas
coller à août puis lui en lui en premier
disque n'a plus le droit de dire moi je
suis pro trame dans comme le milieu
artistique dans mieux que de tous les
milieux médiatiques tu sais comme
extrêmement mal vu pire effectivement
avec raison mais de deux ans les gens
qui sont produits en béton les thés ça
exclut ce dialogue que tu parles
j'ai l'impression que le monde qui
disent rec tabarnak moins
j'aime j'aime certaines de ses idées
plus à toutes les autres me dis juste un
petit café que chris heatherly cave plus
sacrée qu'une séparation est encore plus
grande j'ai l'impression c'est l'une des
seules d'affaires qui faisait un peu de
sens de ce qui est dit dans cette
segment de l'entrevue les membres
d'ecône il se pose partout c'est le gars
qui prend le plus ses médicaments au
monde n'a notamment pas ça pour la
chimie c'est parce que je pense que
c'est un fait je pense pas que c'est le
ghana mais c'est pour ça il faisait pas
beaucoup de sens mais c'est ce segment
là j'ai l'impression que comme toucher à
quelque chose
oui le dire je comprends je comprends
que peu plus le droit de dire il ya
certaines idées que j'ai pas le droit de
dire ça parce que si tu dis ça en titane
est-il raciste est investi de
conservatoire c'est ça c'est mon ami
vision plus dans le milieu je suis
libérale mais dans le milieu
pas plus dans le milieu que quelques
jours c'est ça c'est oui à des affidés
qui sont ici c'est pas faux un vrai
manque évident qu'il est le fait des
faits qui divise et qui fait que ça
discrédite qui dit mais essentiellement
c6 c'est le fruit de beaucoup de gens
qui font taire comme ça c'est pas la
même façon selon moi c'est pas ma façon
de procéder c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
arriver à faire quoi moi je pense
maintenant les tic les conservateurs qui
sont pros tremble mais qui sont capables
de réfléchir par eux-mêmes je suis
persuadé que si il y avait un réel
dialogue avec des experts de tous les
murs qui il était amené à écouter ses
dialogues la passe de cannes du
sensationnalisme extrême puis comme des
débats qui sont juste pas des bottes et
à télé mais qui avait des vraies
conversations que ces gens là place de
dire que les autres c'est votre cas
d'autres ceci n'est qu'un petit tiers de
vraies conversations jeu persuadé que
j'ai l'impression qu'on atteindrait une
espèce de
un espèce de vérité qui plus grande que
juste deux camps politiques - parce que
tout est possible en moins c'est un thé
pour libé tout en déposant jeudi pour
exactement effectivement c'est
d'expliquer mes temps d'expliquer aux
gens qu'ils sont protégés pourquoi leur
président c'est un et racistes ont été
de dire je comprends que vous vous tenez
à des enjeux économiques ou ses
politiques etc sous y fait que vous
voter à droite comme ça c'est correct
mais voici pourquoi lui c'est pas la
bonne personne pour vous représenter
voici pourquoi lui c'est ce qu'on peut
lui en même temps mais aussi georges une
image du peuple aussi les i c'est
présentement on est tellement tanné de
se sentir qui ont fait dire des âneries
tout en gardant un langage quand même
aux autres comprends pas ma personne
préférés de l'année amendable pendant
débat des chefs à vos questions madame
merci vais tous vous donnera d'amasser
ne dit rien comme toi pour répondre à la
question de piste et c'est tellement de
madame la seule à madame la plus oui au
monde jusqu'à ce moment le parti et je
sais pas combien de fois j'ai écouté ça
ça fasse pas vrai jeu non non non avec
deux mois n'était plus long que cinq
minutes de débat
tout le monde qui a parlé samedi on a
parlé personne ses filets des mesures à
la fête le bye bye mais non mais celle
enclenchée tout le monde avec deux demis
plus beau #primaire s'étoffe et si en
plus on est toutes cherchent tous les
gens des cités de tlf est ce qu un
étudiant du cégep du vieux répondent pas
un mot ce que je voulais dire c'est que
ces épisodes pour notre québec n'ont pas
vraiment les hommes
pauvre hashtag pas vraiment même mec
québec pas vraiment elle le suit avec
deux mots c'était le monde générale de
tout le monde se débat des chefs
ennuyant et toute la politique qu'on a
eu pendant toutes ces années je vous
pose une question est ce que vous avez
répondu
photo non mais j'te rien faire c'est
tout elle tout résumer l'histoire québec
aux policiers avez vous est ce que ta
réponse à votre question pas vraiment
cette madame le temps d une pension
quelque chose c'est pas comme c'est si
simple qui se passe pour sa jambe et pop
là pour ce que je pense que tu chantes
doit être élu c'est que oui de la
marmite la mangue qu'on comprend des
langages dans l'engagement on comprend
que les gens compréhensif au top mais
c'est vrai qu'au québec on y 55% de
il est très fonctionnel et beaucoup de
monde en 2006 est un club et nous et
tout ça pour dire c'est que même le
monde comprend ce qu'on dit c'est ça
même la vente qui comprennent c'est que
des fois ça veut juste qu'il engage pour
rempli de se remplir une demande de
subvention sinon ma paie pour avoir des
subventions de l'austin harmonium foutu
pas un langage que personne clooney
comprend pour avoir la subvention pour
avoir une possibilité d'avoir cette
subvention le puis j'ai rencontré je
demande le local à 4 mai à tahoua
pitarresi si je fais c'est parce que
tous les calques et l eur puis à
résister le langage qu'on me dise on
comprend pas darche même façon que vous
le comprenez non plus pu m'ont dit on
comprend pas trop non plus on vote à
vous et là des fois je vais me disent
ouais si ça sert plus qu'à se pose une
question le site dodge à cycle divisé la
question pour répondre fait bruit ce
monde là les prochaines régions n'ont
plus de sens prêt je pense pour ça qu'il
faut être né sommes encore compétences
la personne doit être le plus celui du
mal est fait pour que hillary clinton
est au club en même temps c'est manqué
pour nrj clin d'oeil et aucun poids pas
sa trempe
c'est juste parce qu'il y avait de la
même si madame de louis marc
ils manquent comme t'es mais au moins tu
t'es tu sais que la ram un ouais c'est
tout ce qu'il m'a fait je viens tu me
comprends que des mecs acquittement
c'est plus rassurant
hays clairement en train de manger au
moins tu sais c'est plus rassurant
quelqu'un qui te manque que tu sais que
quelqu'un qui faisait le compte de de
réconforter avec la bougie cas d'école
je pense
compris comme d'année un décor c'est de
la bauge est comme ça je suis dans mon
vote clairement la bonne mais au moins
je le sais un suffixe qu'on est rendus
là je pense moi est revenu encore le dj
toutes ces scandales la russie c'est
tout tout tout est possible mais audard
matrice mon homme
il faudra éviter commente ses sorties
commentées vie nomade évident graber bas
de post et à la dot a dit ça ya aucune
façon des mots clés sur 20 ans
qu'est ce qu'une façon personne d'autre
dans le monde est capable d'éviter ces
personnes auraient pu s y est arrivé le
nouvel arrêt d'occagnes avec aux
maternelles d'expérience est fini pour
donner un gain limité car qui les ya dix
jours mais je mets ma main au feu le dis
si donald trump été élu et si vous êtes
élu le jeu de ma démission parce que je
connais je comprends rien les politiques
lakers en expert en politique puis le
cac était élu le cueillir venu puis à la
tête basse à tabarnak les autres ben
ouais je les mettrai une personne
incroyable je sais pas d'où vient le nom
je pense que c'est rien ils vont venir
pour voir autour des usines et les
clouds cerro rico des arrêts comme tu
dis le comment se dote grave robert est
aussi senti tellement long mon corps
j'ai vu que deux chiffres comme au
hasard et c'est ok aymen se promènent
leur présente chez spie seraient membres
de cobra sur wallace catabase plus
confiance en toi quand les médias dans
le fond ouais que juste à dire que les
médias sont corrompus les médias c'est
un phénomène qui est là dessus et hop
à tort c'est que je choisis très bien
sur quoi manger hearing manche aux
affaires confins calice congrès d'eelv
et les médias sont corrompus que cnn
n'est pas parfait mais c'est quand une
source plus fiable que donald trump
l'ancien nantais faire mais juste le
fait que ce plan social une source
fiable new york times et plus fiable qui
est dans l'outrance je dis pas le
contraire mais parce que ce que montre
était il ya un média qui est de la
marque possiblement tous les médias sont
en larmes se donne ça viendra mais c'est
fait la bresse et 2c de ces deux termes
là il va retourner à la télé là pour
casser c'est sûr que oui c'est j'avoue
que s'attaquer aux médias c'est assez
simple considérant que les médias sont
quittés au bout de ce qui est possible
de l'être
j'aurais intérêts humains derrière tous
les médias au québec où si tu es bon ben
ok surtout québec si au québec c'est une
personne qui contrôlent pratiquement
tous les médias mais le québec le mandat
les gens se disent non plus méfiants au
québec en police y arriverait peut dire
et tout les médias c'est n'importe quoi
c'est des mensonges en allemand en fret
à pullman 6 ie6 pierre karl péladeau
était resté chef du parti québécois qui
étaient en élection pour le devenir
premier ministre du québec sa sortie en
tabarnak
ça serait sorti le stade du mans terre
lol c'est tout c'est tout ses opposants
auraient fait chaque fois qu'ils
allaient avoir une nouvelle dans le
journal de montréal/journal québec
lui veut acheter la presse mardi il veut
comme acheter toutes les journées une
personne va pas céder tous tes billets
ces problèmes à 6 m
aof aux états unis et le monde à claques
à télévision parce qu'ils étaient la
prison par beaucoup de deux mois par
rapport au web au québec
quebecor tu écrases et le web toutes les
médias ils ont tout au tout au tout au
tout statut un peu le rêve des hommes
comme moi c'est fait c'est fou le mirror
en iran cela mais au showcase où ça va
sortir demain comme dans une couple
d'années même encore là dessus je
faisais une coupe des coupes deux mois
d'avril soit démasqué à tva nouvelles
qu'elle a fait leur concocter une force
nouvelle que deux mosquées avaient
empêché dire des femmes d'accéder à un
chantier c'est quoi ce truc c'était une
journaliste qui avait dit que deux
mosquées dans côte des neiges avait
grands chantiers de construction les
deux mosquées avec mado chantier de
construction de ne pas se présenter que
des femmes devaient pas se présenter sur
le chantier
le chantier lé vendredi la construction
du phare - parce que c'était le jour de
la prière de vendredi étaient fausses ou
vraies elle s'était fait aider mon
triste et pauvre et plus tard qui sait
cela n'a fait plus hâtive et à tva mais
je vais être au nom de même elle avait
juste décidé d'inventer quelque chose
ben ils sont partie prenante d'une sauce
ma nation pauvre fille la source mon
pauvre vie leur suspect fait qu'elle
était répartie confronter les deux
mosquées nazaire on en est on à
l'épreuve sur papier on lit on à
l'enregistrement aux amis de saper
l'idée était comme les deux chefs de la
majorité comme jean et une pour des
vélos et on n'a jamais dit cela
on nage ici que faire attention de
connaître ce qu'on ait accès aux
parkings vendredi parce qu'on a la
prière c'est tout ce qu'on a dit on va
vous montrer pour vous montrer les
informations retrouvées
je commence tu es pauvre il n'y avait
pas d'informations trouvées parce que
c'était pouvait se demande n'avait
jamais été fait saine
sauf qu'ils y ont fait de tébéo fait une
excuse mais si j'ose dire si ce ton
excuses doivent être aussi gras ton ex
cudl et fait le mal est fait
convaincu de mettre la mains des
talibans c'est surtout quelque chose de
choquant c'est que tu dit dans cette
information-là du monde qui attendent
juste une erreur
une poisse pour des tests et des pythons
ton excuses doit être aussi grande que
ton froid rage foirage monumental
monumentale mais c'est un peu j'ai
pathétique de la pression à qui la
nouvelle en principe qui dit crise c'est
chaud on en parlait double vérifie pas
dans leur super un petit peu de rigueur
journalistique qui suivent pour le monde
a fait comme tes bonnes nouvelles de
l'est toujours premier set mais c'est ça
ce qui est des nouvelles comme ça des
fois qu'ils sont tristes et où
débarquent à quelques jours les erreurs
dans l'est dans les journaux je me pose
des questions c'est vraiment le meilleur
parce que c'est le truc c'est maintenant
les journaux massa travaillent au
salaire vient d'annoncer à québec
d'avoir travaillé très exactement c'est
sa station et quoi mais la réalité aussi
c'est qu'avant cd et cette équipe le
pied vêtements mois qu'ils aient de ce
maintenant c'est d'homme t'écris biya
même pas une institution qui vaut relire
ton texte vocal jai des photos
axé sur castor mais il ya plus les
plumes un contrôle de qualité qui avait
pas ce qu'il y ait plus d'argent là
dedans parce qu'il y ait plus de moyens
parce qu'il put rien n ya fait pas parce
que c'est la loi de la jungle
c'est n'importe quoi n'importe quoi piti
un article un peu l'esprit critique
chèque c'est quoi la source puis mettez
tous les articles se recentre internet
la manne accessoiristes bookmarks et
partager une fake
tu vois des affaires tu lis des gros
titres cliquer là dessus rempli de mardi
à hier l'article sur martineau ce nom
c'était déjà investi d'articles ou
est-ce que ils disaient qu'ils ont
est ce que tu disais tantôt ça mais ça
passe à gauche le sait lui 10e étant
acquis au de nos jours mais ton
tu es noir tête des points bonus mais
c'est en plus noir et guy le taux double
point bonus c'était un handicap it tpiy
lui bon celui-ci ça finissait par
station
ça finissait par se tasser puis la
sphère qui était derrière ce serait que
plus tu avais de de différence plus tu
avais davantage ce qui est à mon avis
pauvres et considérant que chris mettons
la fille qu'on dit dans tôt le femmes
lesbiennes noires handicapés nêne même
genre et or avec coulissement des prises
en société dans laquelle on vit entre 10
à laquelle tu sais richard martineau
prendrait sa place parce que le
désavantage est sûr que non jamais
devant les dans un esprit par contre oui
mais c'est vrai que ces gens là bas avec
toutes les marges dans la rue je me fais
arrêter où je conduis un char qui
vraiment qu modifie ou qui a pas de
raison et parce que ce champ le est
plaqué sinon ma copine ben me fais
arrêter mais je comprend d'où ça vient
c'est normal on parle de plus en plus on
donne de plus en plus d'espèces de voix
pour parler plus en plus et oudot déjà
marche dans le puits c'est une bonne
chose
oui on n'est pas rendus au point puisque
ces gens marchent les élus ont un
avantage aux pouvoirs supplémentaires
sur les québécois de souche moyens n'ont
pas la vie normale mais je n'ai vraiment
pas d'accord aussi plus de temps avec
une conversation non version ce genre
dans la vie tous les jours non
l'année de toutes ces différentes
strates de personnes n'en ont pas les
mêmes années martin au cheval des
nouvelles séries netflix n'est plus
c'est quoi comment s'appelle ou quoique
ce soit mais c'était comme un personnage
gay handicapé mettons ce personnage qui
avait plusieurs télés bon encore les la
gauche qui est la nana qui exagèrent
pitt sopi je m'en coller ce qu'est une
série d'accords sur un lourd handicap et
égayer le tir 99 et cyril procès des
blancs face et qui n'a eu plein de joie
ce terrien que mu dray le rien que cela
martineau qui prend de quoi enfin exaucé
son article il sépare au québec on est
tolérant mais il ya des limites
puis je cette phrase le moi je peux
rebondir sur ce que tu dises eu cette
phrase le cette chute le à un article je
me suis dit combien il ya de personnes
qui ont vu cet article a passé puis qui
ont rien dit qui en fait on va publier
ce stade les lions mais après ce métis à
celle-ci de l'opinion le lui chrysler
mais c'est de l'opinion mais mais ces
informations non mais je m'en fous un
quintet des éditeurs dans six boîtes ne
ya du monde
les textes et du monde cliquer sur métal
et bois lui crise politique dans son
salon mène à apprendre son texte à un
médecin sur la page web à cliquer sur un
top en même temps j'ai douté plutôt
ennuyeux youyous droit maintenant mieux
tout à fait le droit d'en situer en
mangeant mieux vendre légitime a le
devoir de s'assurer que ne pas partager
des textes qui font juste encore une
fois qu'on faisait donner une raison à
quelqu'un qui cherche juste des raisons
pour agir mais tour là où tout peut
définitive tout peut devenir une raison
d'agir si je mets mon côté la fille que
tu gagnes anthony cela je prends mon
temps la roumaine
qui microbes accroît sa marque et j'aime
canadien c'est quand même très sachant
ce qui avait poussé son mari pour
s'arrêter là la femme d'origine roumaine
moi je vois ça ça peut faire sur point
qu'est ce qu'un bon jack les maisons
seront prêts à tout pour être une façon
de sombres en focalisant elle est
exigeante analyser la chose d'assez
maison mais tendance dans ce contexte le
jeu parce que c'était en réponse à la
parade la prime puis pour moi un martyr
comme ceux ça fait juste donner des
raisons à du monde qui cherchent des
raisons de détester les diversité
sexuelle souvent qui attendent juste une
raison d'agir des gens qui cherchent
juste assez mais de façon x ou y
c'est moi c'est juste ce que ça fait là
au pire au pire
ferme ta gueule mais s'il suffit je
considère que si siri jean martinon qui
fait qu thaïs le prince pour son
lancement la preuve c'est la personne
qui dit petit prince pause casse
puisqu'il fait goreux mais non mais de
tout à fait c'est la fin c'est plus
c'est plus dans l'éducation que de ce
qu'est ce que j'ai fait est-ce que tu
blanchi complètement les mains quand une
tribune tu l'utilisent comme ça
comme je comprends que c'est
l'instructeur et et ce même principe
avec les radios poubelles à québec
le problèmes minant celui dans son champ
astuce est vrai jeff fillion de raison
le problème n'est là je comprends mais
est ce que c'est est ce que c'est ça
enlève le blanc sur la personne qui
prend la parole t'inquiète pas
d'incitation à la haine claire déjà
frappé leh dans la rue le foot je pense
que tant que port d'un station concrète
à la 1
mais ces décisions on fait ce qu'on veut
qu'on dispute en tout il faut pas faire
au dessus mais ces personnes ne soient
tues moi je veux savoir comment les gens
pensent qu'on prend ce jeu je vous
acquiescez le fond tu as pensé jeff non
moi je savoure comme un défi oui parce
que parce que tout le monde qui est là
quel à l'esprit critique de faire ce
travail là bas c'est le travail de tout
le monde sinon je lis beaucoup de monde
qu'ils ont peur les gens vont
s'interroger pour d'autres choses moi
j'essaie de me concentrer sur moi ce qui
est déjà forte je peux m'arrêter acquis
maintenant ils disent aussi bien qu'aux
yeux du monde vont prendre ce hobby
français pour ce qui assurément qui
prennent qu'est ce que je dis prennent
ça pour se cachent pour les grands de ce
monde peu près n'importe quoi de ce
qu'on dit qu'ils peuvent pour du cash
qui qui partent sur des temps gens qui
ont pas rapporté hier des trucs et des
gens qui lisent jls est lucie suppose
que je vis mes rêves que jeudi puis
prend de partir une tangente
waouh c'est pas ça qu'elle a dit le thé
etc etc et juste lit ce qu'ils disent
que je devais te dis je dois sur le
texte arrête de penser à tomber mention
mettez pas empêcher les gens parler des
changements que je comprends je faisais
tout autant droite de publier quelques
chars la différence évidemment jeudi
richard martin on parle depuis des
années puis je dis pas tant se tait je
veux pas empêcher si gens leur parler
sous prétexte que quelqu'un parce que le
problème que je vois c'est que c'est
juste un article qui dure deux
paragraphes qui et sensationnaliste qu'
aucune nuance qui fait juste ce toi
danton vidéo de 8 minutes ou est-ce que
tu décline sa pensée dans un podcast
comme ça où est ce qu'on parle dans un
livre dans un essai dans un article de
fond un ses nuances on s'entend que la
boîte le seul essai de la cse la femme
et moi un problème si je dis pas tu peux
empêcher richard martineau de parler
dire j'en fais moi un article comme du
monde deux mois un article que je vais
les voir ce que tu décline ta pensée
pour de vrai fait pas juste un esti de
taux sur un nappe tienne avant d'aller
se coucher
envoi chatons et d'histoire puis tout le
monde fait ok c'est gold saucer rendu ce
qu'on veut publier on veut mettre sa on
veut que les gens soient exposés à ce
moi je trouve que ça c'est de comprendre
tout le monde pour des caves de juste
diminuer le dialogue
c'est l'important de dialogue je suis
d'accord le richard martineau son
opinion choc on leur seul vrai ici qui
serait quand le ciment nuancé que ça
serait bon de dire ok mais non tu
laisses en place par l'insee on n'enlève
pas la parole ce soir quel point il
chauffe
il faisait un vin bien avant ils étaient
les lancers mais je pense c'est juste
parce que c'est ce qu'ils vendent
c'est ce que j'exprime depuis 30 ou je
trouve que c'est ça le problème trouve
que comme la direction de comac et hong
hong et la presse puis lorsqu'on fait
maintenant c'est comme comme un peu
narcissique
enfin on fait des articles y avait là
légitimité avant tu étais la france
est-il de tête des gens qui ont été
connus parce qu'ils étaient des bonzes
des bons journalistes des bons écrivains
mon éditorial des bonnes éditorialistes
qui la tue fait juste leur dire inquiet
tchèque tout ce que vous faisiez terre
est à vendre
on va réduire ce fait juste comme comme
s'il faisait bouillir du but du bouillon
dans la porte le tout clos c'est
l'appareil ce qui reste est celle
bouillon one c'est quand même qui
maintenant vont reprendre ce domaine
même si c'est comme si on invite qui
coûte exactement c'est ça exact mais
dixit la gueule pour survivre puis le
lui pense lui passa sa job puis quand
j'écris ce g déclic quand j'ai déclic
mon boss est content quand je dis c'est
que j'ai de l'argent je c'est l'éclipsé
la pub pousser les consommateurs kick
son bo prend malheureusement qu un
déclic d'un déclic je m y penser mais
c'est bien le fait que richard fait ça
permet à d'autres personnes d'avoir un
job à sa place je comprendrais mais je
comprends la raison mais si je veux je
pense que richard c'est ce qui fait
toute évidence ce sont impeccables c'est
ici si tu fais ici pourquoi il fait
maintenant
maintenant est ce qu'on peut et est-ce
qu'en tant que société on peut
questionner la moralité moi est ce que
ce sont des dames seulement alors mon
[ __ ] on attend ça c'était un an plus
tôt c'est exact bref c'est d'enfance et
seuls des aveugles
feront ils répondent qu'ils s'étaient
aussi des fois t'es défaut faut pas
confondre non plus réponse à 100 sur
tout le monde veut s'assurer non te dit
quelque chose on te répondre puis c'est
[Musique]
le problème c'est que depuis des années
personne te confronter
on a été confronté à ce que va dire dans
ce qui était un peu de la marne mais
faut que la disent nous on ne sait pas
pu écrire des lettres ouvertes qui
espère exposer à des défauts que la mare
des sortes d faut que mon enfant réduise
la marque pour jean l'épaule mais mon
enfant dit dame en vaux rêver du stade à
m'en excuser que j'en ferai pas je
verrai cisma posons pour ce commet
voisines notamment que je vois les gens
qui pensent comme ça mais tu mets ton
camp mais je pense que deux personnes
qui ont lu cet article qui ont fait toi
et crise comparativement aux gens qui
ont répondu
puis que ces articles ont été vus par
deux sa personne je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
la réponse
moi c'est moi moi ceux qui ont vu chacun
de nos bulles mais maintenant qu'ils
partageaient ce dans mon entourage sur
mon facebook
c'était jawad2 faut laisser ceux ci
exactement cesser d'amadouer la compo
vraiment si c'est exact
moi j'ai l'impression justement si fait
ce puits qui continuent à avoir des clés
cas est lui prend la main que c'est pas
par 200 personnes perdre
c'est sur ces seules ces années amener
une certaine responsabilité qu'un quand
un tribunal pas souvent on n'a pas
souvent je trouve que tu as une certaine
responsabilité morale quentin tribune
c'est pas vrai que maintenant mais j'ai
pas choisi qui me disaient non c'est pas
vrai or est ce tu peux pas juste laver
les mains du monde le sait quand
justement parce
modifier ou de perverti ta pensée
téléthon je pense pas que les radios
poubelles à québec
il pense tout vraiment ce qu'ils disent
sauf que c'est sensationnaliste ça ne
faut pas réagir
le ch flotte avec eux que j'ai pas le
droit de dire parce qu'un ministre ne
peut pas y penser
ouais je sais pas mais j'ai vu des gens
passer des trucs comme ça je sais je
vous résume apposant que ces gens
londres tout à fait sinon c'est sûr la
main pour qu'on en parle
censure pas la mab qu'on en parle sinon
on part de rien mais ce serait trop
souvent la même ville pour les autres
conneries le pour commencer à censurer
les gens mais je crains besoin d'en
parler par an dans les armées des outils
si besoin pour pouvoir en parler je
prends tes arguments pichot pour les
différents par un parent quand on voit
la discussion c'est exactement ce que
vous faites c'est sophie ah bon tu vois
ce que je peux faire je peux pas je
poserai richard s'opposer sans barbe ce
que je ferai pas je pense que
l'information g puis je ferme les yeux
je peux dire à la presse des choses il
ne veut rien dire y est pour nous autres
nous personne ne doit rien fait qu c
soit fathom virer de bord je forme mes
affaires à moi - ferme à la map la forme
de mon côté richard fait à blanquefort
votre combattant un petit vois ma
plateforme qui voit un public emballé la
lettre elle dit
moi c'est ce que je peux faire c'est
georges pour faillite et dans certains
des bonnes quand je pense à l'histoire
des actes watrone 3 une des voies des
réponses à ce qui était le plus entendu
plus le plus les plus importantes
ce qu'il faut nous au titre tu disais tu
manges plus au centre
seppi quand vous écoute on re en sans
peau des billets idée logique non on dit
pas aux sons carabine at elle tient son
cap et dentelle quand ils arrivent ils
situation vous réfléchissez vous faites
votre propre opinion libre des fois des
fois vous êtes même pas d'accord non
mais c'est plus pour seul but est bon
même
sauf que sauf que des fois des fois tu
dis crise qui est ce si ce qu'ils m'ont
poussée à droite c'est plus à gauche
mais mais vous n'êtes pas dans
l'émotivité sévit tenter d'être dans
l'objectivité dans les faits le plus
possible si c'est ce qu'ils ont ce qu'on
veut ouais qui justement c'est pas comme
à ben mes amis ou hôtel group auquel je
m'identifie pas d'âme en fait je me
conforme et 50 kg perdus comme hamid bon
avec qui kiev pape lui même
j'ai déjà vu une émission le soja
soulevé l'exemple est en fait pour
gagner mais bon on fait des barons de
danse ont fait des bébés des jeunes m
débarque dans ses films sipi tau pt
avait beaucoup de monde que je connais
qui étaient dans ses missions le rhin
dont ton des juges puis s'assoit on ne
sauve si la vidéo où est ce qu'on disait
que cette émission le head et paula
comme on dit de la danse mais c'était
bolen la la après la famille la juge
c'est comme ça cette casserole ou est-ce
que c'est comme mais il fait qu'ils
aient reçu pour ses parfums d'âge
espérer une évolution wayne on comptait
vider au lynchage
je suppose que notre ministre effectue
sa prison en même temps si je fais de
commun je comprends je suis pas d'un
chevauchement ya vraiment mon opinion
reste la même jamais je n'ai je
comprends que tout défendre libre tous
les projets ta force et c'est correct
mais pas de problème c'est joseph ce qui
vous a fait comme bon et ça fait mal
mais elle agit pas menti exactement
c'est elle at-il vraiment placée en moi
mais c'est ce que j'ai perdu le que je
pars pull cédant vie mais on devrait
être capable on devrait être capable
d'être en désaccord sans que ça devienne
personnalité puis elle la critique est
un fait elle le clip non merci le prix
personnel c'est comme s'il avait t qui
elle personnellement quand je sais pas
s'il s'agira forcément c'est pas ça
c'est positif et j'ai fait comme tout
justement entendre je te fais de la
danse dans mon milieu
tonnes responsabilité il faut si fortis
de quoi peut-être rien mais peut dire
que tu tombes moscovite une
responsabilité c'est ce qu'on disait
mais affecté directement ce que rexel je
viens avec le français je comprends mais
si tu peux aussi répondre me dire je
pars le collector peut-être est-elle
raison puis moi je pense que je
contribue pour de telles manières t'es
tu penses à répondre à ce moment là
vraiment des gens âgés pause canada pcc
12h15 je comprends ta station jamais de
change d'avis eu de rythme et puis c'est
tout ce que righi ce que j'ai déjà fait
à temps ce qui fait le sais pas ça
recommence à tourner la roue pourrait se
faire dès mon point le mont point à ce
qu'il volait pas si important ce que
j'avais je vais tirer le feuillage
change pas de position
brett pourra voir que c'est ce qui fait
changer d'idée mais j'ai toujours été
cette personne fait du sommeil et et
d'autres instances parce qu'il ya du
monde cherche pas pu à cause de ça c'est
sûr ah ouais c'est ça vous passez ceux
observés un peu à ce qu'on disait au
début c'est tellement vous êtes
tellement courageux même de battre vous
êtes tellement game de prendre ces
sujets le d'en parler le même comme ça
n'a aucun rapport
surtout aujourd'hui où est ce que le com
on marche au 2e jour pratiquement toul
vous abordez tous ça fait du bien vous
avez gardé tous ces sujets là il ya une
autre
on invite en haïti pour faire partir m
une comédie fait la bonne enquête le
soleil de midi jeu dommage que la façon
que certaines personnes traitées ces
hauts lieux du colorisme labeur parce
que dans la même communauté en s'ancrant
base et par couleur quand même ouais
puis on a fait jeudi au moins waouh on
est venu pour nous on ne bat en effet
avoir fait un jeu vidéo parce que moi je
savais que ça fonctionnait comme ça la
bande à lama et si j par liszt
d'autres questions choc de voir dans ta
face au roi daft shylock tout haïtien
paye pas ici bah ouais j'y étais bien
qui va être les items dramatique fait
que cette vidéo c'est sûr que ça doit pl
c'est sûr que nous on se fait plus
jamais revenu c'est sûr que on ne fait
jamais que ça va leur parler
non seulement ça mais toi au sein des
communautés à montréal aussi ça peut
être j'ai pas mangé mon homme je n'étais
pas d'accord le ont encore beaucoup de
monde était d'accord du monde n'était
pas d'accord on s'est fait insulter
encore le mais regarde j'ai soumis
schmid est là et c'est chaud mais vas-y
tu es tu au gip a menti je me se base
sur des faits gêné timo logis g
l'histoire de la chose je sais où est ce
que ça vient
schumi de la chaux middle east peace et
ça s'arrête là non j'ai pas envie je
dors bien sûr ça va
j'aime particulièrement quand vous êtes
justement pas en accord parce que ça
amène encore plus l'attention sur le
fait que c'est des questions qui sont
vraiment nuancé et puis le l'exemple que
j'ai en tête c'est quand vous parlez de
la coureuse africaine l'afrique du sud
doit que caster semanya ces médias way
qui comme une coureuse avec un taux de
testostérone vraiment élevé que les deux
vous êtes quand même pas d'accord avec
la posture
je viens ici avec elle parce qu on y est
on si ce qui est des fois c'est qui on y
porte pour la prétention d oeil
il ya un problème on vous amène la
réponse c'est ça vous allez poser la
question
faut qu'on en parle
viola ça s'en vient pib qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
score 2 2 comme en défense comme si je
parlais à cause d'eux des pinottes notre
pas là et zepa côte vraiment accro s'est
basé sur des nations la défiance est
effectif histoire de deux petites
balises de femmes lucky une femme femme
qui je l'empêchais sociaux chacun mais
mais mais on ne sait pas mais c'est pour
ça le but des olympiques de célébrer
meilleur dans la meilleure à côte en
voici je n'ai vu que toutes les
affections génétiques
si si je n'étais pas là des athlètes
génétique grave prend l'intérieur trompe
ramé donc il laisse ses pôles que sont
cambre et produit son propre fait sous
la bannière mais en même temps je
comprends des cloches comme je voulais
laisser courir moi je mange très mitigé
[ __ ] je les vis qui achetaient biaisée
des cars qui croit qu'on est bien et moi
je vais l'avouer je dirais il a su je
suis biaisé parce que là c'est la seule
raison pourquoi j'allais serait courir
parce que c'est pas un sport de combat
là c'est un sport de combat moi j'en
fais des sports de combat pis si ça
m'intéresse pas le si dans les faits les
secours et le site trio différent en
entendant dans le même genre il ya
différentes catégories de poids pour une
raison le transmettrait pas avec un
poids plume qui passe en ville yves jean
pèse deux fois son poids poids normal un
peu plus mais ça s'est passé comment vis
tu le sais pas si dangereux
effectivement un homme avec une femme si
différents membres sauf que la
testostérone qui plus élevé qu'une femme
qui change la danse de sa densité
osseuse sa masse volumique musculaire
dans cet opus qui fait dans la main dans
la main dans la même classe de poids de
vue c'est passé par des médecins ce
geste est le même pour longchamp ce don
chances de y
d'ailleurs si ça s'est vue d'aider des
personnes trans qui étaient des femmes
trans qui tabasse quand même dans
d'autres femmes trans am points en fait
si on s'est fait défoncer well as you
have 6 ouais je me rappelle pas c'est
quoi la faillite mais ouais parce que je
sais que c'est aussi dans une ligue de
bourgogne en parlait de septembre
gagnant m
ouais ouais ouais ouais je passais par
un autre dans une clinique
mais c'est juste parce que ces temps je
veux pisser le commentaire que j'ai fait
pour sa personne ce com annonce et
transphobes nom sexy dangereux si
physiquement dangereux c'est que les
gars là est pas 30 1 et 4 ans et mes
fans jusqu'à avec leeds la piste bleue
ça change la composition musculaire si
c'est comme ça ce serait dangereux de la
fac on peut tenir dans un sport de
combat
si je sais que je vis ici est plus
distant par de combat l'on veut ce tuer
[Musique]
c'est fou le fruit d'aidé percevra donc
si si si le basket-club ce qui est bon
est ce que je dis que c'est pas transcom
non je pars très net que cette personne
n'a pas le droit d'exister au parc parce
qu'ils te sens pas mais il faut qu'on se
pose la question parce que là on a la
vie de sept personnes au moins devraient
pas être imposées quelqu'un
mais non sauf que si si on dit au quai
menaces au sport de combat il ya un
avantage en fer qui est là pour quoi
qu'on dise pas qu'un avantage en fer qui
est là quand on parle de course quand on
parle de natation bernois y en aura de
la course comment ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne en vagues c'est lui valent de
temps j'y fais de l'athlétisme comprend
la deuxième chose c'est que on n'a pas
de course
sinon c'est un pot-de-vin davantage leur
ai juste la course pour la course hommes
femmes
ces vies nos femmes tennis j'ai dis pas
que c'est là je suis la meilleure lol le
plus beau sport c'est pas le même sport
ces jeunes aquitains jeunes et aînés
seraient traités l'éthique et je dis moi
serena williams je la bosse et 0,03 un
choc immense et je veux qu'on puisse
considérer sont exempts ce qui est
techniquement ne sont pas techniquement
ma blonde sur pattes il ma blonde manet
ans il d'une vingtaine d'orateurs
emmanuel plus de technique que moi mais
je suis plus gros et plus forts plus
être capable on oui j'ai fait de la capa
drama sort l'a fait de la cabrera plus
longtemps que moi un peu pas non plus un
beau paul est bon pour une coupe même m
émeut pas passée je nom de mes amis qui
fait du 10 où la raison que je peux y
passer des trucs c'est juste à cause de
ma grosse ordre parce que à ma grosseur
égal à grossir
fini le comprend il ya une différence
d'un physique le fond c'est dangereux
ici très
c'est juste d'un code pénal fonds de
l'athlète intersexe le thé condé qui ont
des caractéristiques autant aux hommes
et femmes le type qui sait ce qu'il ya
des gens qui logiquement c'est comme
cela qu'est ce tu as if he ou la ligne
tu sors je te faut qu'à une liste que je
t'ai vu je n'ai pas la réponse exacte je
vais juste posé la question parce qu'il
faut qu'on en parle pas si la l1 mais si
l'on veut au total on parle de ça ça se
passe passe en ville il ya déjà un
combat de six fait le pen la fille s'y
fait
il en sortit un mégaphone les amis de
travail pour le voir mais travaille pour
les sports américains viennent de passer
une loi pour le circuit universitaire de
sport sur les athlètes 30 puis ils ont
juste basée dans le fond la donner sur
un niveau d'hormones pour calculer les
catégories fait classe il dit maintenant
on appellerait plus sûr techniquement
hommes ou femmes c'est ça deviendrait en
eau de x en mode excité fait que ça
serait seul est catégorique faire comme
sopite ses bases et scientifiquement sur
ce par contre lorsque ça amène c'est que
ça c'est pourtant le cas de cette lettre
en ce sens que des athlètes comme
justement cette coureuse là où est ce
que vraiment kasri torché par des hommes
sauf qu'il a failli arriver que c'est
dans votre demande encore des athlètes
transe
depuis quand appliqué au monde parce que
quand péter hermans un taux élevé
d'hormones
c'était quand même développé méthode a
été un homme de ta vie comme si tendance
à se sous la pression et en tranchée de
cette façon là j'imagine qu'ils ont eu
beaucoup de comités épique ayons déjà
arrivé à un point où est ce que je sais
pas quel point y avait des comités
d'éthique là dedans mais il y avait au
moins des comme des comités des
scientifiques qui ont dit c'est sûr
c'est parce qu'ici la solution qu'on
peut trouver vraiment que la solution ce
serait effectivement d'avoir comme un
peu en sport de combat de dire de faire
des bras kate de deux genres physique
mais il se pose la question fait pas de
quelqu'un ici non mais non non quoi que
ce soit c'est parce qu'ils ont après on
aura peut-être sa mort n'est pas raciste
c'est pour une question
ouais je veux savoir dispose laquelle on
a un peu moi de quoi que ce soit je veux
juste qu'on ouvre les débats mais ces
actifs on peut même pu ouvrir un ebook
c'est par rapport à ce jeu me logger
suit adam koné conover supposer qu'il a
fait une série qui s'appelait adam
rooney bretagne sur sur internet qui il
parle ce matin puis à lui comme ultra l3
gauche l'ubci comme c'est tout le monde
n'y aucune différence entre les sexes et
jusqu'à la génétique si je sais c'est
juste des doyon l'apprentissage société
suisse la défense est un construit
social exacte tout s'intégrant social
pis c'est vraiment le débat dans
quelques jours logan détruit le plus la
personne devant lui mais parce qu'il
fait juste poser des questions lauréats
comme rien préfet le genre est dit
quelque chose comme itunes france qui
est pour lui sans mettre une généralité
puis joe hogan fait comme non peu
importe peu importe la cause ce propos
de l'existence et grossophobie que soit
la transphobie petit peu importe même si
la cause est super bonne le mouvement
espère importants pays du moment quitter
vaincu
l'objectif
et pis la science et la tantôt parlé de
ses rustines on est avec ceux ci offrent
aux faux pas chez les personnes obèses
of course popov aux pôles et les
insulter il faut pas sûr que tout moment
exprimé à dire des choses comme non mais
a finalement adopté et mettons des
groupes anti grossophobie ti qui vont
dire que non il n'y a pas davantage
présentes et d'être en surplus pour opi
il pas vrai que nana na na na na what he
said à tout ça arrive à tous les
jugements ou skis et amman et de com qui
montent trop extrêmes qui casse la
science dans sa science de la science
comme hmm hmm mais de l'autre côté
m'imposer de la grossophobie d'autres
aussi c'est pas parce que tu es dollars
en titres et non son sentiment sur le
quai pour manger de produits animaliers
à la table on entrevoit vente et citait
pas bien dans ta tête
google fait pop attendant la santé
mentale des pas enchantés que c'est même
plus que je l'écouté du baril partie de
l'autre côté aussi lorsque il faut se
voit des gens qui font des compétitions
ddd compétitions d'haltérophilie bio
sont un terreau flynn patron philippe à
redon sont pas sentis non mais c'est pas
maintenant et surtout que c'est comme un
poids normal
ajoutez à cette affaire pour tout le
monde mais ça fait trois semaines qu'il
boive ses sensations ses excès de règles
il faut qu'un certain pourcentage mais
phil wright 1 d'abord leurs règles
certaines d'entre elles pas normal ton
corps est fait que des avantages j avais
pas fait quoi ce débat c'est quoi ta ta
ta vision de la chance ça s'apprend mais
c'est moi un avantage ça n'est pas pour
juste du côté de paris passe de l'autre
côté aussi le second sens par an sans
tennis comme un autre un peu d'un
standard 8 mai ça se limite à jamais en
8 mois porte à huit le nom
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ça fait
plaisir et en ces temps qu'est ce qui se
passe pour très bientôt
ben je le prends parti de mike ward way
sur toute la tournée donc je vais
trophée voir là dessus j'ai pas de one
man show présentement parce que comme
dans tous les sens d'être regardé mes
tricks non plus de nous regarder sur les
chaînes et plurielle j'adore puis comme
je disais tantôt mais aussi via ouais
j'avais tellement d'aller voir cette
soirée là c'est vraiment non mais on
passe on passe la forêt moi car hésité
entre deux personnes mais oui ce qui
existe et enfants il existe un show à
beijing auto show which way d'enfants
darfour se loupe des chants arabes
faire les socialos fait 10 kg pis ce
projet la bande puis surprise qu'on
découpe très cool merci maman a plaisir
à lui même